Laura's with us in Richmond Virginia hey
Lara welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave thank you so much for taking my
call
what that honor really to speak with you
I'm fairly new to you and I actually
discovered you online I've been
listening to your podcasts while I walk
and just you've really given me a lot of
hope with the situation that I find
myself in so I recently discovered that
my husband is or we are in two hundred
five thousand dollars worth of debt that
I did not know about how does how do you
get to do I not know about it well I was
really absent from handling our finances
we have four beautiful children and I
have been mom so we just had really a
division of labor in our house and I
just kind of stumbled on some things
that have happened we're more in therapy
now a lot of things are going on but he
was really embarrassed and ashamed
really stressed out about our debt and
hid it really well took out some
personal loans our house that we were
living in at the time which we no longer
have we've sold it but it really you
know was draining us financially I did
not realize that when I would ask for a
budget she you know I didn't get a real
budget sheet so there was some
dishonesty very just lack of
communication I wish you would come into
our lives five years ago but
unfortunately this is where we find
ourselves and so we're doing a lot of
work but I have been just combing
through things to try to figure out a
plan and I came across you and I think
that nothing happens by chance and God
brings people into your life for a
reason what kind of debt is the two
hundred in size so personal loans credit
card debt and it really was everything
was really just for the care of our
family and traveling and things that we
never ever should have been doing but
you know I think that unfortunately my
husband is a great man he's made some
really and stupid choices and living the
lifestyle he was
covering euros overspending by lying to
you and borrowing the money to cover it
and that's the that's the extent of the
deal here absolutely you know and shakin
responsibility and we are seeing a
marriage counselor saying of counselor
absolutely we're both Christian you know
we're going to work through them what's
your household income um so he makes
about one hundred and forty five he's
got a great job that's good news yeah
that's really good news but even with
that the monthly minimum with everything
was on six thousand forty one dollars we
were we've been doing a lot of work and
we were able to get some of the loans
consolidated with a little help so now
the monthly payout will be about thirty
five dollars I'm sorry three thousand
five hundred forty dollars I read about
this the debt snowball I'm currently not
working but I am committed to taking
whatever jobs I need to to get us back
on track
we do have four kiddos who are just
wonderful kids and help today so I think
what I need is some guidance from you
like I hear the cutting up your credit
card definitely um so we're using just
one credit card not cut it okay enough
of that fun no doubt right and and so
the other thing that I think is really
weighing on me we actually had sold our
home and moved to a different state you
know and we were hoping to we moved here
in hopes of buying a new home and all of
this but obviously that was before I
knew anything done that was going on
I've listened to you that you say if
you're in debt you can't afford a house
right you can't afford a house right now
and you're going to get a house and
you're going to get your life back but
it's going to take you a little while to
dig through the two hundred and five
thousand the good news is you have a
really big income to do that you guys
need to be on a written budget get on
every dollar calm use the free online
budgeting tool for the two of you to
work together cover that in your
marriage counseling sessions go over
your budget
cut it cut it cut it cut it live on
nothing and if you throw seventy
thousand dollars of your hundred and
fifty thousand dollar income towards
this you'll be debt-free and three
and then you'll be able to rebuild and
that's where you're going to be hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show